obviously it makes me feel like I'm dry
or Pharrell because in my mind I am
that's what GarageBand does it makes you
feel like you can do the impossible and
then you send your song to your homies
they laugh at you it doesn't matter
cause I don't laugh at me and GarageBand
didn't laugh at me
hey what's happening GQ this is Aldous
Hodge and these are my 10 Essentials
first up my sketch pad
look at this beauty bam this book has
been with me as long as I have been a
horological designer
foreign
I started designing watches randomly for
a school project and I sort of became
enamored with the idea of the movements
the intricacies of the composition when
it comes to gear trades things like that
I just Dove deep in around like 18 19
years old and I've been designing ever
since as you can see it is very much
well worn I've kept it up with the
Advent of magical tape every now and
then I'll throw a sticker on there as
you see Black Adam the most special
sticker here is this one Golden Heart
when I had my daughter she was born
early she was in the NICU for like two
months they used Golden Hearts to tape
their wires and breathing apparatus to
them so this is one for my daughter she
represents everything for me strength
belief hope and that's what this book is
all my dreams in here everything comes
down to that first design so this is
probably my most prized and precious
material possession
when it comes to Drafting and designing
you need a good pencil and that leads me
to my number two essential my Muji
mechanical pencils
[Music]
legit I love that store I love
everything Muji it's just
amazing they give you the most simple
basic things in the best package
possible but for me
0.5 millimeter pencil this thing is what
I use for every single thing it's how I
start it's how I finish if I am sitting
anywhere and I do not have one of these
pencils I get a great deal of anxiety
because then I cannot work I just love
Muji they do some cool stuff I go in
there I buy about 20 30 40 50 pencils
just so I'm never in short supply you
would not catch me out in these streets
slipping just saying boom I gotta carry
all of this in something my Tumi book
bag
boom kill me first of all every time you
get a bag I love how they monogram it
ABS you know I'm saying got me feeling
important got me feeling special and
fancy I'm like okay I'm Mr high jump in
here you know you know it's practical
it's well made but they also have really
nice designs when I think about design
DNA I think to me has that
I got some hand sanitizer got to keep
that on hand you know what I'm saying
code without any streets be wild I got
some lotion because you know ashy
Knuckles is it's a situation not about
to be out here shaming my mama I
specifically look for the bags with all
the compartments that can hold all of my
stuff sketch pads my pencils to my
computers to my paperwork to my passport
all that I don't know why I need all
this stuff I mean this bag is at least
50 pounds probably why I got back
problems in fact I'm gonna go out on the
limb and say it is the reason I got back
problems but it's worth it because I
need my stuff that leads me to my next
essential which is my laptop
[Music]
essential number four this is where a
lot of my life lives because I got a lot
of things to put up on this and Joint
obviously final draft because if you're
a writer that's a staple things like
solid work SolidWorks is premiere for
any sort of designer or design engineer
iMovie when it comes to editing it's
actually pretty awesome and GarageBand
whenever I'm writing a movie I by no
means am a producer but I like to play
around with a garage band to create
tracks that I use to become the pulse of
my films as I see them in my head plus I
got two terabytes
yeah oh that's a lot of space we're
gonna move to literature
Holy Grail right here when it comes to
horological knowledge I'm Shuffling
through these books right here to go do
my my Fang
George Daniels his brother wrote the
Bible Georgetown is watchmaking it's
going to teach you about practical
application to horology also
got complicated watchmaking
Francois liquid me if anybody digs into
watches you might know that name
and then this book right here by J.R
Caswell horology it gives you the base
foundation so that you can approach the
mathematics and easier way simplifying
any complicated means of design is how
you define your own DNA as a designer
simplify everything
number six what is the culmination of
learning those things practical design
now I have a non-working prototype
people are always saying well why do you
have a non-working watch because you
show the process you show the progress
jumping into Black Adam I immediately
hit my manufacturing partner I want to
just show a piece of scope of an idea
what it could be and you know show that
on my character because the filmmakers
were gracious enough to let me do so so
I created a peace unique dial the dial
itself was a dial that I designed
explicitly for my character Carter Hall
to represent his lineage there are
different iterations of his backstory
but one of them is Prince Khufu he was
an Egyptian prince I looked through the
Egyptian Book of the Dead as a motif for
the style that I felt was quite
significant and representational of
Carter Hall for who he is and where we
meet him in the film you know we have a
lot of temporary metals like brass steel
calf skin on the strap a butterfly
deployment class but the design is not
final lies but you know this allows me
to get a sense of the feel on the wrist
and the weight so for me this will
forever remain a huge Staple in the
process that
legitimizes me in the space as someone
who is committed to the true craft of
virology at the same time it allows me
to wear something super cool in the film
and I get to also wear my own prototype
that I've also been working on for about
15 16 years this is just a very early
step towards the process of something
that you will see hopefully very soon
your boy loves
jewelry but look I'm not trying to be
bling now that's not the point very much
a different trait than making watches
both my sister my mother are gemologists
this ring right here now the primary
Stone here is garnet colors match
hogman's costume beautiful wonderfully
perfectly but I chose Garnet because it
is my mother's favorite Stone so for me
there's a couple personal ties there but
this is a ring that they made for
Hawkman which I wear proudly in the
movie which I'm really grateful for and
I love I'm going to cherish this forever
when I think about men's jewelry and
being able to have creative options Dave
and yerman is a spot I love what they do
I mean right now I'm wearing two of
their gold chains box chains I'm also
wearing two of their spinel pieces their
spinel necklaces which for me I love
just because the stone spinel is awesome
it also is very similar to my other
favorite Stone which is black diamonds
as you see here boom and boom boom boom
boom boom boom it is a diamond
that is not highly prioritized or highly
valued amongst the space of diamonds but
it's one that I value greatly in all its
Darkness
it still reflects Grand light in the
greatest way possible being an actor
coming up I've been opposed to simply
because of the color of my skin but I've
had to shine baby shine in this little
Stone I can find some kinship in that
even if the rest of the world doesn't
look at you in the same way or values
you the same way you still deserve to be
valued you still are beautiful so for me
I think black diamonds and I will always
have a relationship now we move on to
essential number eight your boy got to
smell good I got to smell fresh
incomes YSL the noodle
[Music]
[Applause]
obviously you see I've used up most of
it because this stuff is awesome it
is cool to find a cool loan that works
with your whole body like people don't
realize you can't just spray on
something it's going to smell good on
everybody it mixes with your natural
scents metabolically creating a whole
new scent and some folks walk around
here feeling good feeling like they're
smelling fresh they just be stinking
me when I tried this song I found my
spot my place and I was like oh this is
it this is hidden this is my goal and
that pushes me to essential number nine
Carol's daughter now Carol
we never met you and your daughter
whatever y'all be making I really
appreciate your work I deal with a lot
of dandruff sometimes be a little dry
because you know your boy doesn't drink
a whole lot of water like I should be
looking like the Alps up here your boy
be flaky in these streets and I'm not
ashamed to just let you know and this is
definitely a staple grow up knowing
about Carol's Daughter obviously got a
mom got a sister you know what I'm
saying so for some reason it hits it
works and it smells good back to this
back to the sense people lesson of the
day
smell good
simple
[Music]
I had gotten a really bad Brash breakout
over my face in the middle of shooting I
was like I gotta go to work the next day
this looks terrible how am I gonna fix
it up so I spoke to a great friend of
mine Miss Debbie a legendary makeup
artist so she put me in touch with her
colleague Dr Syeda Salam who created
this brand shuishi her and her sister
both of them are black women who started
this brand who understand
hyperpigmentation who understand how the
skin is affected especially dealing with
gradients and variations when it comes
to different types of ethnic skin things
like that her products know how to deal
with all of this wonderful chocolatiness
I've been rocking with this product ever
since 2018. I take it everywhere I go
every single set of mine I'm using
shuishi there are many other cool
Products that come along with what they
make and I would present them now but
unfortunately my lady took them all
because apparently in my house hey let's
share this means she gonna take it
especially when it comes to good skin
care products so your boys out here
barely holding on so Dr saeeda can you
hook your boy up with a couple more
pieces on the low low so I can hide them
from my girl I'm not ashamed to admit
I'm finna hide all my good stuff cause
she keep taking my stuff my people
thank you for taking that Journey with
me these are my 10 Essentials love love
love sharing this with you I hope you
take it home with you so thank you for
watching and I will see you on the next
one peace